Trascrizione: Giada Farina
Revisore: Giulia Sgarbossa
Questa che vedete,
è la discarica di Gazhipur
a Delhi, in India.
È una montagna di rifiuti.
È alta 65 metri,
che in realtà corrispondono
a un edificio di 20 piani.
Questi rifiuti creano
un cocktail di gas tossici
che contaminano aria, acqua e terra.
Qui invece siamo ad Accra, in Ghana
dove ogni anno vengono gettati migliaia
di tonnellate di rifiuti elettronici,
come i nostri cellulari
e i nostri computer.
Pensate che un uovo prodotto
da una gallina ruspante
nei pressi di questa discarica,
supera di 200 volte i limiti
di sicurezza alimentare
stabiliti dall’autorità europea
per le sostanze tossiche.
E queste sostanze tossiche causano cancro
e danneggiano il sistema immunitario.
Ora, sembrerebbe che questi
siano casi estremi
lontani dalle realtà
di molti di noi, giusto?
Beh forse sì, in apparenza.
In realtà, le nostre scelte,
i nostri acquisti, i nostri rifiuti
possono avere conseguenze sull’ambiente
e la salute anche a distanza di chilometri
e una crisi dei rifiuti
può colpire ovunque.
Basti pensare agli operatori
ecologici di Parigi
che, qualche mese fa, hanno smesso
di raccogliere rifiuti per 15 giorni.
Risultato?
8.000 tonnellate di rifiuti
accumulati per le strade,
trasformando l’invisibile, ovvero
ciò che gettiamo in un contenitore
per poi dimenticarcene l’attimo dopo,
in una crisi sanitaria
e ambientale ben visibile.
Una crisi che Napoli
ha vissuto intorno al 2008,
quando io lavoravo sulla mia tesi
di dottorato sulla gestione dei rifiuti
e passavo accanto a cumuli di rifiuti
bruciati per strada.
Questa crisi, in realtà,
andava avanti dal ’94,
e ha tristemente contribuito
a elevati livelli di tumori in Campania,
soprattutto nella cosiddetta
Terra dei fuochi,
senza contare i danni ecologici.
Ma riflettiamo un attimo.
I rifiuti,
prima di essere tali,
erano cibo, oggetti, materiale
da costruzione, insomma, risorse.
Risorse che, in generale, si utilizzano
come se fossero infinite.
Ma in realtà non è così.
Oggi abbiamo bisogno
di più di un pianeta Terra e mezzo
per soddisfare i nostri consumi
e gestire i nostri rifiuti.
In pratica non diamo tempo
alla natura di rigenerarsi.
E se continuiamo così, entro il 2060
avremo bisogno dell’equivalente di due,
tre, o addirittura quattro pianeti Terra.
Quindi cosa si può fare?
Beh, la soluzione sta nel passare
da un’economia dell’usa e getta,
economia lineare,
a un’economia circolare, dove le risorse
vengono valorizzate e riutilizzate
in un circolo virtuoso.
E come si fa?
Beh, primo, ridurre la produzione
di rifiuti fino a eliminarli del tutto.
Secondo, utilizzare ogni cosa
al massimo della sua vita utile,
evitando gli sprechi.
E terzo, passare
dall’estrazione dei materiali
alla rigenerazione della natura.
Attenzione, però.
Qui non si parla solo di pensarci
due volte prima di acquistare qualcosa,
o di separare i rifiuti
in diversi contenitori.
Questo è il minimo.
Qui si parla di cambiare l’organizzazione
del sistema economico con le sue regole
e i suoi giocatori.
Una missione non semplice
ma neanche impossibile.
Per esempio, in un’economia circolare
si riutilizzano oggetti, mobili, abiti.
Si riparano gli elettrodomestici,
i cellulari, i computer,
e si disegnano i prodotti in modo tale
che durino il più possibile.
Si riducono gli sprechi alimentari
e si redistribuisce il cibo invenduto
che può essere ancora consumato.
Si riqualificano gli edifici
prima di costruirne di nuovi,
e si migliora la qualità dei terreni
tramite pratiche agricole sostenibili
tra cui l’agroforestazione.
Ed esistono alcuni esempi pratici
di economia circolare.
Ad esempio, in Francia una legge
sull’economia circolare ha stabilito
la riduzione del 50% dello spreco
alimentare tra il 2015 e il 2025.
Per legge i supermercati di una certa
superficie hanno l’obbligo di donare
il cibo invenduto alle associazioni.
E i ristoranti devono offire la doggy-bag
per portare a casa il cibo non consumato.
Questo serve a non sprecare
10 milioni di tonnellate di cibo all’anno
che corrisponde a un costo
di 16 miliardi di euro
e a 15 milioni di tonnellate
di anidride carbonica,
il 3% delle emissioni
di gas ad effetto serra della Francia.
Amsterdam, sta puntando a diventare
una città totalmente circolare
entro il 2050.
Lì hanno creato 150 piattaforme
per la condivisione di oggetti, servizi
per esempio, per chi ha bisogno
di utilizzare l’auto o la bici
solamente per qualche ora.
E sono in corso 116 progetti
per sperimentare principi
di economia circolare.
Dalla riutilizzazione
delle acque reflue piovane,
alla produzione di energia
rinnovabile prodotta localmente,
alla riutilizzazione
di materiali da costruzione
e alla promozione del recupero
e alla riparazione degli oggetti.
E in Italia?
Anche in Italia ci sono dei progressi
Infatti gli ultimi dati rivelano
che la percentuale del riciclo dei rifiuti
è tra le più alte d’Europa,
sfiorando il 70%.
C’è ancora spazio, però,
per investire in eco-innovazione
in modo tale che i prodotti,
appunto, durino più a lungo
e nel campo della riparazione dei beni.
Quindi molto è stato fatto,
ma c’è ancora molto da fare
e ognuno ha un ruolo importante
in questa transizione dall’economia
lineare all’economia circolare.
Ad esempio a livello politico
i sindaci, gli amministratori, possono
sviluppare strategie di lungo periodo
di economia circolare.
Coinvolgere cittadini per trovare
soluzioni per scambiare, riparare,
riutilizzare oggetti,
migliorare i servizi,
ripensare le città per le persone
e non per le auto.
Rigenerare la natura in contesti urbani
e costruire in modo efficiente
e non solo costruire.
A livello di impresa, esistono tanti
modelli di business circolari
dalle app per comprare
abiti di seconda mano,
alle piattaforme di condivisione
di mezzi di trasporto,
all’utilizzazione dei servizi
invece che di cose.
Verso quello che si chiama
dematerializzazione.
E a livello individuale, bisognerebbe
consumare di meno, meglio
ma soprattutto essere consapevoli
del nostro impatto sull’ambiente.
Kenneth Boulding, un economista
degli anni ’60, distingueva
l’economia del cowboy
dall’economia dell’astronauta.
In pratica, il cowboy è
il simbolo delle pianure sterminate
del comportamento vorace
dell’economia lineare.
Nell’economia dell’astronauta, invece,
la Terra è come una navicella spaziale
in cui la disponibilità
di qualsiasi cosa ha un limite.
Ecco, noi siamo come dei cowboy
in una navicella spaziale chiamata Terra.
Pensate che questo possa funzionare?